i don't know if anybody noticed this but
mechagodzilla stole the big g's ultimate
power attack
can you guess what it was well we will
show you what it is
in this video today by now i guess
almost everyone has seen godzilla vs
gong and for those who haven't well
that must suck ever since the first
godzilla movie that came out in 1954
the monsters have had some really
terrifying powers and these
range from the atomic breath to the god
rays of mothra to the
gravity beams of ghidorah and all these
kaiju has some
sort of magical powers it won't be the
same without these things
it would just probably be some gigantic
dinosaur flick
but these kaiju had to spice things up a
bit
so before we go in deeper do not forget
to subscribe to be a part of the
minecube family
and now let's get down with this
sickness
well this video is about a specific
power that we kind of hope
godzilla would have in the movie but was
instead given to his arch rival the
mecha g
so first let us just go through the
different powers that godzilla
has had over the years and also what
mechagodzilla has showcased in earlier
flicks
godzilla's signature weapon is his
distinctive powerful atomic breath
her godzilla's dorsal spines grow
ominously blue
and then let's loose with a concentrated
blast of radiation from his mouth
this power is oftenly mistakenly
confused as fire breathing
although it isn't the color of the
atomic breath corresponds to the colour
of godzilla's dorsal plates
he also has had nuclear pulse and the
goofy magnetic powers and more
in earlier movies in godzilla vs mega
gears godzilla's race was shown as
having
incendiary properties and was strong
enough to destroy an artificial
miniature black hole while in godzilla
final walls it possesses incredible
range power and pinpoint accuracy
able to hit a target in outer space and
kill most kaiju with a single shot
another variation of the standard blue
atomic breath in the hasty series was
the powerful red spiral atomic breath
which he acquired as a result of
absorbing fire rhodan's life energy
the red spiral atomic breath or the
spiral beam attack
was used in the heisei and the
millennium films most notably the
final wars and was expected in the
monster verse as well but did not really
happen
as planned so what about the rival
mechagodzilla it has always had and
possesses enormous strength and was made
of
space titanium in the earlier movies and
although we don't know what it was made
of
in godzilla versus gong and we kind of
hope is some sort of
highly durable alloy it was equipped
with an enormous
arsenal of a weaponry including eye
beams and energy being fight from this
chest and missiles on its fingers knees
toes its shoulders which can also
function like darts
it has had powerful beam attacks since
its first inception
and it can shoot it from its eyes its
chest and also from its mouth
the beam attacks have always had many
names and it is always colorful and its
names
are somewhat like the space beam the
cross attack beam
and in godzilla vs kong it is called a
proton scream
but is it really this proton scream
looked eerily similar to one of
godzilla's ultimate attacks
yes the power looked very much like the
spiral heat ray of godzilla from the
late heisei movies and the millennium
final wars
it was actually used by godzilla against
supermega godzilla
and it exploded the robot kaiju the
color of the ray changes from blue to
white to crimson
red and then yellow with spirals the
beam can cause a lot more damage than
normal atomic breath
it was made famous in the fight against
skies a ghidorah in final wars
and against destroy in 1995 so in
godzilla versus gom when it was first
used against the skull crawler
it kinda looked like any normal red beam
attack
only when mecha godzilla obtains the
power source from the hollow earth
did the power evolve into the spiral
heat ray and you can clearly see the
spiral beams
around the main beam when it fired
against the city when it came out of the
facility
during the power beam dual against
godzilla the spiral heat ray was clearly
more evident with
more powerful spirals clearly it was the
ultimate atomic ray attack of the g-man
from earlier movies
it is expected to be more powerful than
the basic atomic breath
although in godzilla versus score it was
renamed to the atomic ray
even then the spiral heat ray aka the
proton scream
would be obviously be more powerful and
therefore it was able to beat back the
atomic ray during the fight in hong kong
but to be fair godzilla has overused his
breath over the span of a day
from making a hole to the center of the
earth to chasing down the big ape
his breath volume would have lessened
down
so yeah that's the power that was
supposed to be with godzilla instead
of mechagodzilla who should have really
had something more of a
modified gravity beam since it was part
ghidorah in design
or something more of a laser beam since
it was made by humans
anyway it got the spiral heat ray and
rebranded it as the proton screen
you almost got away with it maybe toho
missed it but
mine cute did not anyway it's been a
blast and we have come to the end of the
video
do hit that like button for support and
subscribe to be a part of the mind cue
family
and also smash that bell button for
regular updates on monster videos
right here on minecube take care fam